all right I mentioned Pete Prisco from
CBS sports.com Pete you're shaking it up
here a little bit thank you helping me
do my job
recap your your story here with what the
Cardinals you think are going to do at
the top of the draft yeah I do not think
you're gonna take over again obviously
subject to change but from what I've
been told it'll either be Quintin
Williams or Nick post and I think
they're leaning more toward Nick pose
and obviously you know there's been some
talk a lot of talk about Kyle over me
and I think a lot of that had to be
ownership driven I think the ownership
group strongly considered in but I think
the football people would rather grab
the defensive player and stay away from
take it a quarterback particularly after
trading up last year you don't forget
that they trade it up to get Josh Rosen
and unfairly I didn't give him a chance
to succeed last year so I think find out
a lot but I think they're gonna pop up
Carla Road I guess the only question I
had about that is you bring in Kliff
Kingsbury and yes he's a quarterback
whisperer but if you're bringing in
Kliff Kingsbury it feels like you're
doing something maybe drastic or you're
gonna change things up philosophy wise
that's where I thought Kyler Murray
makes more sense with Kliff Kingsbury
than Josh Rosen does yeah and again
probably soul in that office but if
Kingsbury's as good as they think he is
it's good as everybody thinks he is and
he can make Josh Rosen work in his
office as well and again you gotta work
to what you have not fit what you want
to your office then and the other thing
there Dan is Kingsbury is not making the
decision remember he didn't even get to
hire defensive staff the Cardinals hired
his defensive staff for head so that
tells you you know what his status is
inside the building and and granted it
could grow and I think he's a smart guy
and a bright guy but also think he can
make it work with Josh Rosen do you
believe that they have trade offers for
that number one pick I think they'd be
open to it I think they're listening yes
I do I think there will be somebody
that's interested more appropriate and I
think the Cardinals will be open to it
now how far down will they go that just
depends of what the offer is but I think
ideally they'd like to boot down and get
some extra picks and still be able to
get a top level player but that means
you're not going to move down that far
do you think that they've gotten
legitimate good offers for Josh Rosen no
I do not I you know I heard one
yesterday and has it validated but that
the Giants have offered them a couple
picks for him I don't know if that's
true and I have a checked on it yet but
I don't think they're getting what they
thought they would get for Josh Rosen in
terms of offers and that's why I think
they're kind of reevaluating it look
they would probably take if they were
going to do it and I know again I don't
think they are going to do it but if
they were going to do it I think they
would take a high two for them I don't
know if they're gonna get that for you
got kind of Marie slipping to the
Dolphins at 13 that's that's pretty good
again this question let's just say for
the argument sake here that the
Cardinals do pass armed and the Raiders
don't take it before where did he go I
mean because I don't think gentlemen it
at fix would say calamari I don't think
that's that's his style quarterback I
don't think John Elway at 10 would take
them because I think he's looking more
at the prototypical stand of the pockets
off the quarterback maybe to lock so 11
to the bangles I don't know Mike Braun
will give up on Andy gold so we're going
to go so if there's always that
possibility that if he doesn't go one
that strange does that sound if he does
not go one he could take a little bit of
a tumble and maybe Miami's disability
closes their lives
Louis Riddick of ESPN was on a half hour
ago and he loves Dwane Haskins like it's
not even close
he's like you know this guy's got it all
and it almost feels like somebody is
gonna make a huge mistake passing up on
Dewayne Haskins what do you think of his
first-round grade so once in my life I
think I agree with Lewis I agree I think
the guy in this dress and I think he
should be the first quarterback taken he
stands in the pocket he can make all the
throws he's a smart kid he's a
prototypical you know quarterback and
granted both fully and Haskins the one
things going to look at the one thing
that the Abadi winners keep coming back
to us
they were only one year starter yeah you
know and that's the concern you know
where's the you know the big talent
evaluation gains to really evaluate I
don't think there's a lot there so
there's some concern but I agree with
Lewis if I had to pick one of the
quarterbacks in this draft it would be
definitely weight asking who changes the
draft would team well I think Arizona
but which team great danger to draft
probably I want to see what Oakland does
I'm real curious there you know you get
a big push for people in the building to
get more defensive help but you know how
John is you know he gets enamored with
those offensive players so that'll be an
interesting dynamic and I by the way
I've heard that man I actually loved
asking a lot so that would be
interesting if they do
I've already sitting there what they do
if they do go quarterback and I don't
think that one quarter how do you know
when somebody's telling you the truth
people believe the person look we've all
been lied to in this profession a lot
and this is the lying season so you got
to try and trust the person and there
are a lot of guys that even you believe
over the years and we also do this for
30 years build up these trust and at
this time of the year they might not be
totally you know honest with you I just
don't I don't care if you're not telling
me that you know the greater truth but
don't lie to me that that that's the
concern if you you know don't throw me
exactly if they don't want to but don't
also lie to me and leave me to different
direction I don't know if the NFL has
changed that teams are looking for an
errand Donald of course hard to find
something like that but that I love
Quinn and Williams like I just think
what he does to disrupt the pocket from
inside up the middle is of such value
quarterbacks always say I can chip you
on the edge it's when you're coming up
the middle I see you you see me and you
know Aaron Donald was so disruptive last
year that's why I looked at Quinn and
Williams and I just thought I don't
think he'd said it's a no-brainer to me
I think he's the best player in the
draft your thoughts on Williams and you
know where he's going and what kind of
player you think he'll be I love them I
love above the power player quick
and remember he moves inside from n so
there's a lot of athletic ability there
as well
I think he you know Arizona you know
failed miserably on larvik mpg I mean
they took him in the first round they
thought he did dominant inside player
and it hasn't worked out that way
so I you know wouldn't shock me if
Coonan was was the first overall pick
either because he is such a good
football player who can also play ended
so for me I think he and Oliver and
Oliver both are going to be really good
inside players on the next level beep if
it comes through you're going to look
like a genius on Thursday night guys
he wants to know if you think he's
looked like an idiot before no comment
no comment
little guys Frisco is calling his little
guy Pete Wow Thank You Pete good luck on
Thursday night they stirred it up a
little bit there for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on be our live
or download the Dan Patrick show app